دي محطه الجمهوريه بتونس العاصمه وجد كمال
نفسه ينتظر ساعات توال عنه يظهر بوسيله
نقل تقله الى منزله حيث زوجته المريضه
بانتظاره امل كمال في ايجاد وسيله نقل
عموميه تلاشى فلا الحافلات ولا المتر
الخفيف يشتغل بسبب اضراب عمال شركه نقل
تونس
المتزامن مع اضراب سائق التكسي الفرديه
حلول
البعض يلهث وراء وسيله نقل خاصه وخير
البعض الذهاب الى العمل او الدراسه مشيا
على الاقدام وسط حاله من الغضب والاحتقال
فما لا ثم حد شيء صدقني شيء اسف وشي حزن
وليدي هنا واحده من نيتها تونس معنيه نصف
المروج هفضل تونس همت منكم على بعضهم
يمشي
امرك باذن الله
الماليه
وصولات الاكل
المتخلفه لمده شهرين
ويكشف الاضراب المصاحب الماليه التي
تواجهها الشركات العامه التي توشك على
الافلاس بينما تعاني الحكومه اسوا ازمه
الماليه
في حركه النقل وسط العاصمه وتزامن مع
اضراب اصحاب التاكسي الفرديه وهو ما خلف
حاله من الاحتقان لدى التونسيين الذين
تقطعت بهم سبل وزادت معاناتهم وليد عبد
الله العربيه